uh so
from uh from a deeply analytical
perspective
uh can you describe why dogecoin is
going to
win which it surely will like it it
very likely will take over the world and
once we expand out into the universe
we'll take over the universe
uh or on a more serious note like what
are your thoughts on the recent success
of deutsche coin where
you've spoken to sort of the the meme
stocks
the memetics of the whole thing that it
feels like
the joke can become the reality
like the the meme the joke has power
in this world yeah it's fascinating
exactly
it's uh it's it's like
why is it correlated with elon tweeting
about it
it's not just elon alone tweeting right
it's like
elon tweeting and that becomes a
catalyst for
everybody on the internet kind of like
spreading the joke
right exactly the joke of it so it's
it's it's the the initial spark of the
fire for a wall street
bets type of situation yeah and that's
fascinating
because jokes seem to
spread faster than other mechanisms like
funny [ __ ] is very effective
at uh captivating the uh like the
discourse on the internet
yeah and i think you can have um like
though i like the one meme
like doge i haven't heard that name in a
long time
yeah um like i think back to that meme
often
that's like funny and every time i think
back to it
there's a little probability that i
might buy some
kind right and so i imagine you should
have millions of people
who have had all these great jokes told
them
and every now and then they reminisce oh
that was that was really funny and then
they're like
let me buy some uh wouldn't that be
interesting if like the entire
if we travel in time like multiple
centuries
where the entirety of the communication
of the human species
is like humor like it's all just jokes
like we're high on probably some really
advanced drugs
and we're all just laughing non-stop
it's a weird like
dystopian future of just humor
you